do you remember your transition from
elementary to middle school do you
instantly think of the burden of
homework less playtime and of course the
stress have been liked by others
as you watch this episode of odd manner
and try to spot the 5th grader I hope it
reminds you of what it was like to be a
middle schooler
we brought together seven middle
schoolers I am a middle schooler
I am a middle schooler I'm a middle
schooler I'm a middle schooler I'm a
middle schooler I'm a middle schooler
one is a fifth grader
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
Christ who is the odd man out
okay the hardest sex I've ever taken was
aspectus that spec test is basically a
two hour long test that is really hard
and I absolutely hate it for me it was
um social studies because like there are
a bunch of people and they they also
like sound the same Hamilton he made a
big George Washington he killed some
people Thomas Jefferson he also killed
some people from the beginning I was
probably most suspicious about its high
and so I really kept my eye on him mine
was a history test
I hate history if there was could be no
history in this world I'd be happy for
the rest of my life yes Luke you're
quite lunch oh my heart his chest was so
I'm in sixth grade but I take seventh
grade math now you know like sixty-seven
accelerated oh yeah so do I just start
talking
I was absolutely gunning for Luke there
was something into him he was quiet
I feel like middle schoolers are
complete extroverts they love talking
well it's like any when you're at school
you learn like there's not much going on
but when you miss a day there's so much
man I mean usually a healthy child and
I'm not really sick but whenever I'm
sick there's always a substitute I hate
my son he's my substitute because she
will let every other can't do anything
bad there sounds like you could go to
the office you could go downstairs you
you go to the recess to get something
that you accidentally left wait you have
recess no I'm talking about in
elementary she said something about
recess I was like you don't have recess
my sixth grade is an elementary school
so we still do have recess so I thought
it was kind of the same for her you've
been a bit quiet
it was it was really hard to talk
because I had tie to my left he couldn't
stop talking okay and smash right now
we're learning about the slope so it's
basically two dots on a graph and you
have to find the difference between
those dots your turn I wanted to be kind
of the leader I wanted people to see me
like this kids not the mole he's way too
aggressive to not to be the mole because
mold people would obviously be quiet
but middle school I'm guessing wait no
it's not ready yet
middle school is a black hole of it's
right okay wait no this is kind of
Burgundy's
this is burgundy okay this is definitely
red no yeah I voted for acne because I
mean I kind of could tell that people
were gonna come for me so I had to go
for someone I thought like everyone was
gonna vote for to save myself
I been studying middle schoolers ever
since they said it's high wanna be in
the odd ones out I was like shoulder I
started was I started analyzing
everything a middle schooler does and
everything I know school wouldn't do
okay so I have seven periods because in
our middle school we have that and they
all have study halls because we do and
in seventh and seventh grade math right
now we're we did rate a change and that
was I didn't really but I was the one
where I missed the day before and I'm a
6th grader because my play and mpg and
elementary I didn't do dodgeball and
this year we do dodgeball and and okay
so I'm in I'm a seventh grader I have
six periods my elective is leadership
and I can able be able to say this
before but my least favorite test or
geography test because there's so many
places and it's like especially when we
have to we have to mark certain states
it's just really annoying trying to
remember all of it and then
for we have to run the mile every week
oh we're right now learning about the
Byzantine Empire I thought he was
smaller and he was kind of quiet I guess
it's because a lot of people say I look
young it could be because of my height
or because of my voice okay you use this
tick-tock oh that's something a low
would say Luke are you in a wall I used
tick tock because the girls always take
my phones and make take time so anyway
what when you guys went to middle school
like your first day we like what were
you most worried about well I hate my
sixth period my sixth grade teacher and
I did not like ty I think I can really
trust him well cousin he he like he
talks a lot like me I wasn't there with
that we were gonna get a bunch of
homework I was worried about my teachers
because like as soon as you walk in
they're gonna be all bawling you like I
know who you is explain I will scare of
like people not liking me cuz I've been
great a lot of people did not like me
the toughest thing about being in middle
school is the people that you go to
school with because kids are sometimes
really mean and they're a judgmental but
yes mostly like they said I was annoying
what same here I don't think you're
annoying yeah I like when I got into
middle school so like my brother and my
sister they all went through the same
middle school as me and I had some
teachers they had and they were pretty
bad kids so when I came in I was like oh
gosh she sees my last name she don't
start with her and then she just gives
me a dead eye I'm watching you well Sara
and Luke they were right next to me so I
was able to talk to them I thought they
were being really really honest and I
didn't think there was anything
suspicious dude
walking into middle school and seeing
like the 8th grades that had mustaches
and I was like this I ain't yes anymore
I have to like look up because I'm one
of the shortest ones so they're like
right here and they're like give me a
high five me like up high I'm like I
can't do it here are you guys born in I
was born in 2007 I was I was born in
2007 I was born 2008 I'm one of the
younger ones I was wearing 2008 but I'm
super smart I'm not like I'm not like
one of the like the short kids like I'm
I'm like the one that goes like excuse
me you there I feel I feel like you're a
grown woman but into a little girl's
body is the way or a Southwest she was
like and her her emotions and what she
did kind of showed me it was like she is
very sassy and Ike and to be honest I
kind of enjoy it die okay so we got to
do this quickly
and my opinion here in the mall where do
you guys eat lunch like we part two I
voted for ty because he was a bit too
outgoing and I thought something was
suspicious yeah I bought a tie out
because I kind of thought he was the
mole and whenever he dropped this card
it said my name
[Music]
I thought like the end of her like she
was writing an H at the end and I was
like oh so we come from me now
[Music]
holy keep me do I get to like say why I
was like what no they I'm determined
fine whoever but it tire I realized I've
been talking a lot and I'm saying and
I'm shooting out people people are gonna
think I'm a mole I realized that a
little too late so that's that was kind
of bad what is a Mik that you've heard
about middle school that like wasn't
actually true like what your teachers
tried to scare you about there's one
myth that I don't they didn't come for
my teacher it came from a lot of seventh
graders for some reason and they're like
oh people getting toe for kissing in the
halls I'm like geez you finna get
detention
Oh yes'm it like you get lots of
detention for little things but it's not
true the seventh graders told me like
you can use your phone in class so I
came in class with my phone and then my
teachers like detention we used to be
able to go to Disneyland but they say
they sent one of the characters on fire
so now we have to go to Knott's Berry
Farm not Disneyland what is the hardest
homework yet you got that you guys have
ever done not anything I remember we had
a project due on Friday and my friend
she forgot the whole thing at home I was
so mad I didn't talk to her for a week
you have sorry dad oh thanks
[Music]
oh my gosh I messed up I was like I
should have raised my hand what I
learned the most is to not trust anyone
everyone is my enemy I'm ready to trust
anybody you can't trust nobody you can't
trust anybody I'm gonna start watching
my friends a little closer and
especially watch my teachers even closer
I can't believe that I trusted the mole
I always try to look out the best of
people and then they backstab you
technically she damnit you know vote for
you much stove back sobs backstab
[Music]
[Applause]
the best part was like being able to
like meet new people I made friends with
Luke mostly all of them especially Sarah
we might actually go to the mall later
are you fine the best part was
definitely meeting two people because
you know it's you get it you get stuck
in the box with some people you don't
know might as well make some friends and
that's exactly what happened Taiyo like
really cool I think like as soon as this
is over like we can get chose numbers
like he seems like a pretty cool dude
yes I will I hope that we could one day
hang out together
maybe you go do laser tag cuz that's
something us middle schoolers do thank
you for watching don't forget to don't
forget to follow at Tyler 0-7 don't
forget to follow the jubilee video this
was an amazing experience I would love
to do this again any day any time don't
forget to follow them there's some
really cool people when white people
call their parents by their first name
I'm Asian I'm Asian I am Asian I'm Asian
I'm Asian
I miss it thanks again can they find the
mole
you